oh yeah let's continue the quest to try
to make up for lost time at Comic got
fun last time that last time so Comic
Con they released a number of trailers
for these comic book movies everyone's
hype for one for Justice League already
talked about that one you check that
video out here on my channel another
trailer that dropped was one for Doctor
Strange and continuing to make Doctor
Strange look like that new elements of
super cool and twisted that you just
want to see in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe guess what I'm trying to say is
it looks the most different I think
that's just pretty sweet in this trailer
we saw but we already saw in the last
trailer which was Doctor Strange he's a
doctor as not just his name the man has
a PhD gets into a wreck his life is
pretty much ruined if not very much
changed now he's gonna train to be a
sorcerer because why not when you lose
your job that's right when people lose
their job some go on unemployment others
beat off old guys behind dumpsters this
guy becomes a sorcerer I like his style
but among the literal reality bending
[ __ ] we see in this movie we can't see
it it's one of the things I'm looking
forward to in this movie it seems that
these sorcerers do things and we human
beings just can't see the effects of it
it's some other underlying reality on
some plane of existence that these
people can tap into so when this is
happening we can't see it but they can
because they're manipulating it I do
want to see some else world stuff I mean
if our existence is one plane of
existence you know it's like there are
it's the multiverse kind of thing layers
upon layers of worlds that are created
out of people making this choice and
then that choice is ease peering through
these things I want to see things that
we've already seen then I want to see
some things that are different outcomes
to what we've already seen in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and it'd be cool to
see glimpses of future events like one
we're at like Thanos one maybe the Borg
took over earth and the enterprise
failed in Star Trek first contact they
can't do that but still he's magic looks
really cool like this see where he had
his hand out and that rune came around
it and that that symbol I was like that
looks like Doctor Strange Mads Mikkelsen
also his duties the villain in this
movie you saw him as the villain and
Casino Royale who's also Hannibal in the
TV series Hannibal is it sadly cancelled
but might be renewed for four season
it's all in the air right now there are
some people who are just born to play
great villains like he's like the
Christopher Walken now as Christopher
Walken was in the 90s yeah in the 90s
Christopher Walken was the coolest
villain you could have in your film now
was Satan eyes I do want to know when
this movie takes place he's obviously
practicing to be a sorcerer for many
many years there's a start out before
the MCU and now is taking place like now
in the MCU this has become sorcerer
supreme at a point when Captain America
and Iron Man were fighting you would
think he doesn't know anything about
what's been going on in the world
because he's training with them the end
of his trailer was pretty funny saying
he gets this piece of paper that says
Shambala on it and he's like what's this
my mantra he's like it's a Wi-Fi
password
we're not savages which I died laughing
but then you're like oh you can't even
escape that I don't know about you guys
oftentimes I've fantasized in my life
what that would be like going to the
Himalayas or something away from
civilization or being wrecked on an
island coming back a few years later
because I just think about that stuff
the constant draw to think about that is
the fact that you would be away from all
the chaos and the social media you just
have time to decompress a little more
than you'd want but now he doesn't even
get that it's like it's the Wi-Fi
password yeah you'll still know about
the election and trump and bernie
sanders and hillary the draw for
seclusions now over it's gone but in the
end I think this looks cool Doctor
Strange is the most intriguing
and weirdly bizarrely detached from the
rest of the Marvel Cinematic Universe
movie that I've seen ever since it all
started I'm really looking forward to
this one does it look sweet but I want
to know what you think about it so the
new Doctor Strange trailer have you seen
it what did you think about it are you
looking forward to it whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more